i want to ask you about your time as a.g
though yeah
no no it's fine i mean when you were
there i mean i know you weren't there
for a long time did you see anything i
mean obviously russiagate was bunk
didn't you have the ability to look into
it to investigate dig into it yeah so so
i supervised the mueller investigation
and i'll never forget and i've talked
about this before
uh in fact i wrote a book above the law
if anybody wants to it's available on
amazon um
and what i talk about uh i don't think i
mentioned a lot in this book but but i i
know i i remember this like it was
yesterday because it was so impactful
is um you know there was a there was a
lot of controversy when i got appointed
uh i had been on cnn as a commentator
before i came to the department of
justice and for like four months they
hired me to you know sort of be the
conservative commentator and
you know one of the things i had said
which was very true which is i could
imagine
that
the president trump would appoint
somebody new that would come in and and
had control of the budget of mueller and
would reduce the budget
there by limiting you know his ability
and his scope and and all that and you
know and i said that just as a
commentator
no plan to do it but then you know sort
of everybody lost their mind when i got
you know became the supervisor of the
mueller investigation it's like i almost
looked prophetic like i planned
literally just
but is that what you did you reduced the
budget or what no i didn't do anything
but but i had to go through a ethics
review
um you know with with the most senior
career
doj official
who actually it was because of the way
it's written it was my decision on
whether i just you know i could consult
him but it was my decision ultimately
and he i didn't ask him to write a
recommendation of course he wrote a
recommendation which says you know i
should have recused because of these
these things i said on cnn and i was
just like this is nonsense i you know
i've i was a us attorney for five and a
half years i know what it's like to be
independent and look at facts and apply
the law and make decisions and you know
kind of my
my commentary as a paid cnn analyst is
not going to affect how i do this job
and you know it's just it wasn't even
apples for apples but anyway so you know
fast forward i clear that hurdle and i
get read into the mueller investigation
and you know the first thing they say is
you know what matt we have
they have not found any evidence of any
connection there's no evidence of any
connection between the russian
government and trump campaign
and i thought to myself well
why do we have this investigation and so
then i then
you know there were several other pieces
and parts and you know one of the things
that i read into for example was the um
roger stone investigation you know there
were several other components of this
investigation that that i was also read
into and you know given a status update
on
but
you know at that point in time you have
a decision to make and you know i mean
it
life is all about you know sort of
replaying did you make the right
decision to make the right decision but
the decision ultimately and if you think
about how the regulations played out
if i wanted to fire bob mueller or end
his investigation
he
had they had to be for cause and so that
was a that was a big hurdle
and you also think about um you know
doing justice is it better for donald
trump to have a full report from mueller
saying there was no connection
or have matt whitaker acting attorney
general shut it down because there's no
point by trump yeah i mean and so you
you it just it it you know i
the two things you know that
that in retrospect i i now believe is
that you know sort of the mueller
investigation was a total hit job by
anti-trumpers
it's i mean it is literally the january
6 committee but inside the department of
justice well what about ukraine as well
same thing
yeah
that was just the the train got rolling
before they realized what the evidence
was and then they kind of were you know
i mean this nancy pelosi hates donald
trump and she had the power to get
enough votes to file articles of
impeachment and improve them out of the
house
full stop i mean that's why it happened
and
i'm sure if nancy was here and was
honest
and not dealing with her husband's you
know legal issues
i think she would say
i cannot believe
you know how tough donald trump is
how you know how hard how hard he fought
how how good his defense was and how you
know he kept the republican party you
know solid and you know supporting him
through those you know those impeachment
trials half the republican party maybe
yeah i don't i mean you lost i think
they feigned support i think a lot of
these guys they feign support i mean all
right name names of like who feigned
support lindsey graham
he comes out like he comes out on tv
that's talking about how he's all in
favor of trump but come on you see him
go you know walking down on the floor
and he gives kamala harris a fist bomb
he's not he's not really behind the
president you look at
you have uh in 2016 and 2018 the
republicans the public republican party
entertained and allowed the russia gate
nonsense to persist yeah they could i
mean you make a good point although i
mean i think you know i think cash and
devin i think we're you know we're
trying to get to the bottom of it i mean
it was just
there was
the i think the thing that we all forget
was just how much smoke
created
by the fbi and by you know sort of the
left
and the clinton campaign how much smoke
there was you had to you couldn't see
through it
because you just every time you you'd
like run into something and be like oh
that's i mean maybe i you know i thought
this was
it just it was it was a shiny object in
smoke and you just it was very hard to
get to the bottom and you know there
were a lot of people that didn't want to
get to the bottom of it because they
wanted that smoke there they wanted to
hamstring donald trump and the question
you know that i come back to tim and i'm
sorry i know this is your show so i
don't want to dominate the time
but what you're here for man what what
is so dangerous about donald trump why
do people want to take him down
so enthusiastically well i got some
ideas it could be that
back in 2009 it was i should say in 2012
it was reported in 2009 the cia had
reported they wanted to overthrow this
uh bashar al-assad the assad family in
syria because we were trying to build an
oil pipeline the qatar turkey pipeline
up into europe to offset the russian
gazprom monopoly and uh syria explicitly
told the united states we're going to
support our ally russia not allowed to
build this in fact we're going to get
iran to tap the same gas field send it
up through iraq so we could basically
steal the oil and then we can control
oil prices into europe screwing with
your allies and so then conveniently for
the u.s there was a civil war in syria
the arab spring occurs and uh
we'll just throw it to we'll fast
forward a little bit to ukraine in which
gazprom controls a large portion the
largest i believe of natural gas flowing
into europe through there now that the
nordstrom pipeline is coming from russia
and all of a sudden you get this
conflict in the euro maidan movement
where
ukraine wants to either join the joint
nato join the eu join nato join the west
or side with russia on their trade
federation and that's all happening
then donald trump comes in and he says
we're getting our trips out of the
middle east well that's bad news if you
dedicated 10 15 20 years to building
this pipeline and getting oil to your
allies in europe but what is donald
trump he gets elected what does he do he
gets elected and sure enough the
conflict in ukraine dies down simmers
down isis is getting crushed abraham
accords well that's big bad news if you
need the conflict to justify destroying
the country of syria to build an oil
pipeline our gas pipeline the qatar
turkey pipeline and now joe biden gets
elected and it's right back on track
exactly where we thought we'd be ukraine
war lights back up we got gazprom back
in the news germany feuding with russia
and you have donald trump who was
telling them the entire time to become
independent stop relying on russia now
that's probably surface level scratching
why they may be mad it's very for
foreign policy heavy you could also look
at domestic policy donald trump banning
critical race theory contracting
companies that engage in critical race
theory trainings couldn't contract with
the united states all of these things
just fly in the face of their agenda and
then you have the personal oh boy was
hillary clinton mad it was her turn so a
lot of reasons why they really really
hate donald trump yeah but boy i mean i
just we i've never seen i mean we've in
our history we've never seen a president
this persecuted um kennedy
although he wasn't persecuted in public
yeah they just decided behind the scenes
i believe that it was time i mean i
think that they whacked the guy i don't
know for sure but i mean there's just so
much evidence that it was coordinated
by whoever yeah i don't know i know that
um
pew research showed that the tr uh
trump's press coverage was five percent
positive five i believe obama's was 40
42 i believe so here's obama the first
thing he does again in office is he
orders a drone strike blowing up a
village of women and children he he
commits extrajudicial assassinations on
american citizens but the media can't
stop
let's just say patting him on the back
for a family-friendly uh way to describe
it plus we're in the air trump comes in
and uh the one thing the one thing they
give him is when he fires missiles into
syria they're like this is it and i'm
like there it is
when he fought when he fires missiles on
an airport in syria all of a sudden the
media is like donald trump's
presidential moment oh yeah starting
wars that's what they love about them
but uh when the economy is a booming
what do they do they lie cheat and they
smear every single thing the guy does it
never ends yeah we never were in the age
of like social media manipulation like
we are now so if if trump had just been
president 30 years ago or someone like
it maybe there have been newspaper
articles but it would have been all a
lot of it behind the scenes because
that's all they had now it's social
media it's slander on the news and all
that crap so we're seeing it for the
first time yeah
yeah i just uh
the fact that he fights through it all
and is you know not only as popular as
he is um well that's why but just like
he's he is never tired i mean it's like
he eats it like a candy bar
uh
it's really it's extraordinary um
just never seen a force like this in my
life and you know i mean i i'm around
him a lot and get to spend a lot of time
with him and and i'm i i sometimes i'm
surprised and just that you know kid
from ankeny iowa uh gets these
opportunities but i also know that he's
just like he's a no bs kind of guy yep
he doesn't worry you know doesn't worry
that you didn't go to yale or you didn't
go to harvard or you know sort of
doesn't another reason
can you are you effective can you get
the job done do you speak clearly and
you know make commitments and live up to
those commitments is those you know it's
just the basic you know kind of what
you'd expect out of a guy that's uh you
know sort of built buildings
i look at everything that's that's
happened over the past several years and
what's happening now with the january
sex committee and there is a malignancy
in this country that is gutting it from
the inside donald trump what do you do
he brought auto industry back to
michigan an investment of i think around
three billion dollars he he cuts out the
tpp he starts bringing manufacturing
back to the united states the best
numbers of our lives jim cramer says
foreign policy abraham accords peace in
the middle east starting to take form
he's meeting with north korea walking
into the dmc with no security you take a
look at the stuff that donald trump did
and it's like wow
one of the greatest presidents i've ever
experienced you know i i i'm reluctant a
little bit to say the greatest president
uh one of the greatest presidents i've
said that before but i'm like okay i get
it i wasn't alive for a bunch of the
other presidents but in my lifetime
the foreign policy actions
not perfect but really good no new wars
getting our troops out of the middle
east trying to make peace with north
korea shoring up our borders getting rid
of the tpp bringing manufacturing back
i'm just like wow all that stuff was
really good for us and then you take a
look at the democrats and everything
they're doing now and it is gutting and
ripping this country apart and it's
because of people like nancy pelosi
nancy pelosi who we know
is enriching herself off of her position
that somehow she just makes these
excellent excellent stock decisions that
everybody's a heck of a stock picker oh
yeah yeah and then people make a social
media account tracking her stock
decisions it gets banned yep you know
you look at the level of corruption the
lies the cheating the stealing and it
just makes me sick and the worst thing
about it is where is anyone to do
anything about it yeah and tim you might
be onto something here because i was
just as you were talking about all that
it struck me recently
that um
donald trump like you said had kind of
brought peace to the middle east and was
disengaging the u.s
from the need for middle eastern energy
and what is joe biden doing he's going
right back there exactly and re-engaging
in the middle east with the saudis and
you know
you know he obviously went to israel i
mean i don't know when i was there last
week
they were talking about
how
i guess he drove into the west bank or
gaza
he went into one of the occupied
territories i hate using their
terminology yeah biden did and he took
off the israeli flag because he was
flying an american flag in israeli flag
but they took off the israeli flag
before he entered um the
i mean i think what do you call that
like the the part of israel that
is
palestine
it's not palestine i don't know who you
ask yeah it really it's that area is so
interesting to me and having been there
now and seen it with my own eyes that is
a
fascinating uh you know history and it's
a current like real politic issue um
it's just i think gaza you're talking
about gaza the west yeah well so i guess
we can call them gaza in the west bank i
don't want to call them occupied
territories because they're not occupied
they're part of israel
but anyway
you take a look at what big tech is
doing you take a look at how democrats
actively support a lot of what they're
doing you take a look at the cult
ideology gender ideology critical race
theory etc and these things just serve
to erode and destroy the united states
you don't see these things in china you
don't see these things in india you
don't see them in as you see them
somewhat in europe but in the united
states it is profound bill maher brought
it up i mean you look at the stuff with
what that's happening with uh kids
getting uh sex change operations this is
happening predominantly in in
hyperliberal areas and non-conservative
areas but it's not happening in other
countries you take a look at tiktok for
instance
the things on tick-tock the overt
wokeness allowed we got banned from
tick-tock we really don't know why it
may have been because we had alex jones
on the show in china they don't allow
the woke stuff
because they know it's it will it will
erode the base of your country but
united states that's that is the law
that is what you have to abide by in
social media
it's almost the more destructive the
technology is for society the more it is
you know encouraged to be used and and
uh and prolific it's really
extraordinary um you know big tech
is i think going to get its reckoning
here in the next uh you know year to
three um
they've been given tremendous powers and
they have not they've abused those
powers we rag on republicans quite a bit
because they don't do a whole lot but i
will say from 16 2016 to 2018
you know
maybe they just didn't realize the
extent to which things were occurring
when they were occurring the way they
were
then they lost in 2018 to the democrats
and they gained back some seats in 2020
but not enough for the majority maybe
come november we're uh three three and a
half months away or about
maybe then the republicans will get the
house in the senate maybe we'll start to
see some subpoenas i want to see this i
want to see joe biden impeached for the
ukraine scandal joe biden engaged in an
overt quid pro quo
it's it's remarkable remarkable that
that that donald trump could discover
this seemingly bumbling upon it and when
he asked the ukrainian president you
look into what that was about they
impeach him for it
because they knew joe biden was their
guy
a made man would get away with with the
crimes he committed going to ukraine and
saying i am going to deny a billion
dollar loan guarantee illegally even
though congress approved it because i
can do whatever i want unless you fire
the prosecutor by the way the prosecutor
happened to happen to be investigating a
company called barisma where his son
worked but that's besides the point
according to the media someone was on
the board of barisma yeah 83 000 a month
and victor shuken was investigating that
and joe biden uh went to the president
said fire him or you're not getting the
billion dollars and the president said
you can't do that and joe biden said
call the president see what he says well
sob guy gets fired that guy needs to be
impeached over that we need a
congressional investigation we need a
select committee we need an
investigation on the 529 insurrection
when they threw a fight when they set
fire to the st john's church in the
guard post force the president into a
bunker i expect to see subpoenas of all
of the biden administration officials i
expect to see subpoenas contempt of
congress everything they can do if they
win and you know that's what worries me
because it sounds too good to be true
but but
do you think merrick garland and the
department of justice is going to
receive those
referrals
of course uh as enthusiastically as he
did the one with you know for bannon and
navarro and
and of course i mean the embarrassment
that they did to peter navarro i i still
this
you know i was i was
my guy this swearing thing is really
i'm sorry i was upset i feel like i was
very very upset
um
that the way that the the way roger
stone was taken down i thought that was
ridiculous cnn are getting typical in
fact you know i was the acting attorney
general at the time and i let you know
chris wray know
uh you know
that that it was not acceptable that
that was that was clearly intentional
middle finger cnn was top tipped off but
you don't need to go i mean i understand
officer safety but we're talking roger
stone is not done anything about it yet
well what i mean you know you can you
can get the explanation yeah um
but you know sort of up operationally
i don't think we want attorney general's
attorney's general involved in
how to arrest someone they're going to
arrest or how you're going to execute a
search warrant i mean that's you know
that's you leave that to the people that
are doing the job this is the issue but
the democrats get in and think the exact
opposite of the way you think they say
light them up burn them down right i
know and then and you see that example
navarro being pulled off a plane uh
shackles you know if you believe peter
yeah he was you know his feet were his
legs were shackled i mean this is nons
this is absolute nonsense i mean he
should have been given a notice to
appear
right it's a misdemeanor remember
contempt of congress is a misdemeanor so
bannon was convicted of a misdemeanor
right navarro is charged with a
misdemeanor we've never i mean that's
the same
and again i i'm just telling you that's
the same as like if you get a ticket
in a
national park i mean it's like it's the
same docket that you see in that case
it's what what is it two month minimum
uh in sentencing guidelines up to two
years
it's up to one year missed
under a year yeah is that all right to
you because he's charged with two
yeah yeah so that is like on par with
like um what driving on a suspended
license
yeah i mean it's federal so it's a
little different uh you can't really the
the state you know state each state has
a different thing i mean i know you know
my experience in iowa having you know
defended
i mean
you would do you wouldn't you wouldn't
go to court on a misdemeanor you
wouldn't have a trial and a misdemeanor
typically i mean that's that's why the
case that's what the case was so fast
right and banis i mean it's like you
know it's just a there were two
witnesses and
it's just
yeah i mean he didn't call any and the
jury was out for three hours and but of
course waited for their free lunch right
um
how long do you think they're going to
send it did
they sentence him yet i i 30 days or
less i'm guessing he might he might just
get like you know i mean he could get
probation yeah
it is um
this is going to be
i hope this isn't controversial but you
know congress has a jail in the capital
and they're starting if they really
wanted to enforce their subpoenas they
would send their sergeant arms to go get
these people and put them in congress
jail and actually you know exert some
like you know some instead of offloading
it to the department of justice
and making it you know again making it
appear to be something much larger than
it actually is
i want to see
republicans win in november in uh the
house and the senate but i don't want to
see your typical republicans win i want
to see people like marjorie taylor
greenwin you know she's she's considered
controversial the media smears her left
and right she's got certainly views that
i don't agree with i don't care she's
fearless and she's she's fighting
against this stuff she's going to
congress and forcing these people to do
their jobs much like trump was that's
why people like trump that's why why
people like marjorie that's why people
like thomas massey or rand paul but they
also like people that fight
and they they want people that stand up
to the just the bs of washington dc that
don't like want to get invited to the
you know white wine cocktail parties
where everybody stands around with a
drink and chortles about conservatives
and you know they want people that sort
of actually are unwilling to play the
game
that are going to go to washington d.c
and they're going to fight for what they
you know yeah
they fight for what they got elected on
and i mean you see you have to be in
tremendous
uh self-confidence to survive that i'll
i'll tell you uh i'll give you a good
example of i think the issue the left
and the right uh of the left and the
right
there was a
a guy who worked a taco bell and he had
a mask on it said black lives matter
and his bosses went to him and said you
can't wear that political stuff while
you're working here and he says i'm not
taking it off and i said if you don't
take that mask off we're going to tell
you to leave you can't work while you
have it on it says fine he goes outside
he films himself and says they wouldn't
let me wear this the activists attacked
a taco bell until taco bell issued a
statement saying you can wear black
lives matter stuff conservatives don't
do anything like that they say well but
if i
do that i'll lose my job it's like
you're right the left doesn't care when
they lose their job and you can argue
well because they don't have kids it's a
fair point i'm just saying when the left
is willing to go to roger stone's house
at five in the morning with cnn being
tipped off and they bring him out this
way and the right is unwilling to do
anything about it or push back in an
equal or or opposing way then you will
get this indefinitely it you know it's
remarkable to me that what happened to
roger stone happened while you were the
acting agent
i i mean listen i i ate i take
responsibility for it it was under my
watch i was in charge of the department
of justice at the time um you know i
mean i
raised holy hell as best i could um but
you know i just don't you know this is
philosophically
the best you can do is know that it
shouldn't and won't happen the next time
because it does
well i mean you know it doesn't it
doesn't i mean you know at least while i
was there we didn't have anything like
that
go down um but you you know this is
where
we have to um
have a higher standard for all
no matter what party you are for all
public servants we have to have a higher
standard
we can't just have our public servants
be
like everybody else
and hold them to the same standard
because it's gonna end up you know as
it's gonna
be just a complete
well you're right blank show see you
guys are killing me the cluster you're
right but here's the here's the show
thank you right now you have
these young progressive personalities on
youtube whatever claiming republicans
are steamrolling everything and why do
they believe that because they think
they should get universal health care
but those republicans just won't let
them
meanwhile republicans are actually
compromising on everything on most
things uh gun control being the perfect
example
when the democrats on the left argue
that republicans are the roadblock
because they're only giving you a little
bit meanwhile the democrats are
arresting
former administration officials which is
like the red flag of all red flags in
terms of governmental collapse in crisis
the right being unwilling to do anything
or saying you know what we're going to
stand on decorum it's like
congratulations stand on your decorum
when they come and shackle your feet let
me know and i'll salute you as you go to
the gulag that's that's what's happening
no and i'm not saying that the the the
right should you you know unilaterally
disarm
uh in fact it's quite the opposite you
know we gotta play the same game they're
playing uh we need to know the game
we're playing and then play it well but
this does not end up well um
you know if we if we just keep smacking
each other uh that's not good for the
american people and that's why the
voters
ultimately you know need to get
the right people i mean i and throw the
ones out that they don't that aren't
working and we need to have we need to
have more primaries we need to have more
you know contested elections and and it
needs to be from the bottom to the top
and it just you know for me
um you know we can't
um
you know
we all learn
as we go and we you know we all adapt
and adjust and i just don't think
republicans are learning as well
as democrats right now thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there